i just i just saw a clip of it this
morning oh yeah brilliant yeah your
scottish accent is fantastic it's very
very natural i've i thought if he's
lived a life of being a warrior and he's
got a couple of kind of nicks and cuts
on him and his hair's long and he has no
vanity and all this kind of stuff i'm
gonna make his voice as grounded as i
can make it because in that group
you've obviously got so many different
dynamic characters and it seems like
archibald sometimes
can can express a little bit of
frustration of like hey guys let's
concentrate we're in real trouble here
you know we need to like concentrate so
i thought i don't want to make him
entirely serious but i want his voice to
be a little bit more the voice of kind
of combat reason totally come on
yeah yeah yeah he's not a sour puss and
he's not too serious but he is to the
point he's like all right all right
enough around let's go yeah
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my pearl